what's going on everybody here is to
deal another comedy video coming up for
you right now a bunch of you liked the
last one I put out where I kind of
described where the joke went like
because I didn't have time to finish it
before Korona and so I told you about a
new punchline that I had written for it
so this video is a story that I love
it's a story about going to get my sperm
count to do a little little donation you
know I'm saying and but the evolution of
it like I can't wait for you to watch
the video and then for me to tell you at
the end kind of how it's changed and
then when we can get back out on stage
for you to see the new video man I love
that nerd comedy [ __ ] and by the way you
saw me turn you saw my sweet ass rake on
earbuds man these things come on man
they are so cool looking and they just
fit right in
here's the thing that I generally don't
like ear buds like this because they
don't fit right but Ray J who is a
co-founder who knows a little something
about fitting something in a hole has
made these where they got five different
little at the end I don't know what
they're called
I think it's technical term and so if
you depending on what size your hole is
he has different little things that he
can fit in different size holes it's
genius guys the sound is next-level
Snoop Dogg uses them and I know he and I
are usually on the same wavelength so I
knew I'd like him the sound is
next-level they don't fall out of my
ears when I work out hey tell me what's
more annoying than an earbud or
earphones falling out of your ear when
you're working out
[Music]
buddy these do not do this guys are
super comfortable they look super cool
come on they they right you didn't even
see that you're like oh look at that
thing in his giant elven here yeah man
they even made earbuds to fit my Legolas
like ears that's what they should say
these earbuds fit everybody even Legolas
oh but I'm telling you some right now
here are the things that I don't want to
forget because they're paying me and you
can't forget about some things a couple
things you need to remember these are
like half the price of the normal ones
like when you would go out and be like
I'm not gonna say the brand you go out
and get this twice as much as this these
sounds so good man the base these new
ones have a better bass line so good
they sound amazing that great for
working at home the great being in the
gym you know what I'm saying there you
can talk on the phone whatever you want
to do and they're slick and they don't
stick out so good these are the everyday
e 25 earbuds that the best model yet six
hours of playtime so for somebody like
me who flies a lot or used to have to
recharge earbuds mid-flight
cross-country it is a load of [ __ ] six
hours of playtime seamless bluetooth
pairing more bass like I said compact
design nice noise isolating fit which is
what I said right in the ear hole no
noise comes out comes to new fun colors
and here's what you're gonna do you're
gonna click the link in the description
below and you're gonna get 15% off your
order go to buy rake on Comm slash Josh
wolf for 15% off your order
brought to you by rake on by it should
be right there I'm fingering it right
now BAM watch me finger that dink go to
buy rake on comm slash Josh wolf 15% off
your order
come on everybody get these in your hole
you're gonna like them you're gonna like
him even more than you like this video
coming up check it out my wife we
already have three kids I mean but she
was talking about having another kid and
I was like that that sounds pretty
[ __ ] dumb
we have all kids like I'm not realistic
you don't go back in for another 18
that's [ __ ] dumb that's really dumb
you know what I mean like if I wouldn't
know what to do with a [ __ ] baby
right now here's what I ears like here's
my theory on babies when you have babies
are like farts because you love your own
but if you had to sit in a car with
somebody else's when the windows rolled
up you'd be like I'm a [ __ ] kill this
[ __ ] right now so but I told her
I was like yeah you want to have another
kid she was I guess use that but I need
you to go to the fertility clinic
because I smoke a lot of weed and she
was like you know weed is really bad for
your semen which made me laugh when she
told me because I was pretty [ __ ]
high and I was just picturing my sperm
swimming around inside of her like
Cheech and Chong like oh no I'm not
gonna smell up there man I'm gonna hang
down near the walls I was like yeah go
has anybody in here been to her
fertility clinic just me and my old
balls okay here we go
well I'll tell you something right now
there are some awkward situations you
find yourself in I've never found myself
in a more awkward situation than being
in the lobby at the jerk-off doctor's
office
because look you're sitting in a lobby
with seven dudes all strangers but
everybody knows that everybody's just
waiting to go jerk off it's bizarre
there's no eye contact some dude tried
to shake my hand then I was like [ __ ]
you we are not shaking hands and look
there's some times in my life where it's
nice to be recognized and there are some
places where I don't want to be
recognized like the jerk-off doctor's
office and and let me tell you why the
jerk-off doctor's office is so weird in
the lobby it's not a secret we all know
we all masturbate that's not a secret
but you but you don't call your shot you
don't announce it to other people do you
know what I mean it's not like the game
Clue where you're like it's Josh in the
living room with a sock do you know
anything like we've got a little more
decorum than that you know what I mean
I'm trying not to make eye contact and I
can just feel this dude staring at me
just I turn to him and he goes I know
you and I said no you don't know no no
no I know you what's your name again
and just send from behind the counter
the woman she said mr. Kameda you want
to come on up here and fill out your
paperwork and I was like okay so I walk
up there now I know none of you have
ever been to a fertility clinic but let
me tell you there are two questions on
the paperwork that I would that stumped
me question number one how do you plan
on making your deposit today
masturbation or other and I was like
well I got a [ __ ] question right now
I said what's other and she goes do you
plan on masturbating I go well it kind
of depends on what other is doesn't it
because if you're sending in nurse other
I'll check that box right now she was
like I can't tell you what it is like
are you telling me there's there's
there's an alternative to masturbation
that's so good you have any [ __ ]
named it yet you're not gonna tell us
what it is she goes I really can't I'm
like okay she goes maybe I can tell you
later I've okay the next question that
stumped me stumped me
how much do you plan on depositing today
I don't know I don't jerk off in a
measuring cup of my house
oh I'm not all of it I'm not gonna be in
the other room like this I don't joke I
don't you're gonne not like I got a
teaspoon and a half today I'm [ __ ]
all of it I don't need a doggie bag all
of it you know what I mean whatever she
was like go sit down I'm like
walk into the lobby and the dude was
like hey man I don't know a couple
minutes later she goes your turn I go
okay I go into the room and I walk into
this room and right away guys I know
there's no way I can masturbate in there
it was a testament that room was a
testament to how gross dudes are let me
tell you how gross dudes are the couch
that I was supposed to sit on covered in
plastic which means they had washed it
so many times that the dude was like
Nietzsche's gonna [ __ ] wrap that up
the remote control that I was supposed
to hold covered in plastic I'm gonna go
one step further and how gross dudes are
the front of the television was covered
in plastic that means some two jerked
off on the TV he was like I don't want
kids
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I was aiming at you though so you know
so I was like man I uh I don't want to
touch anything in here but I knew how
important it was to my wife so I was
like okay and then I remember her
telling me that when she's in to place
in a bathroom that's dirty that she
doesn't want to sit on the toilet she
hovers right you all hover over the seat
so I was like oh I'll just I'll hover
jerk
so I get to write here and I'm
masturbating and I'm about 20 seconds in
and I was like my [ __ ] quads are
burning right I was sweating profusely
I'm like [ __ ] CrossFit this is the best
workout I've ever had in my entire life
I'm gonna come on a [ __ ] open up
a:hover jerk studio and close down
CrossFit like right now I'm sweating I'm
cramping cramping and I'm like I need
some water right so I start to walk out
to the front and I'm sweating guys I'm
breathing heavy I'm cramping so I'm
limping sweat dripping off my face and
I'm walking out to the front like some
weird survivor I'm like
and the woman was like are you okay and
I said I think I'm gonna need to know
what other is she said I can't tell you
that but I get your water I go okay I
drink the water I go back in the room I
finish up I come out I go to fill up my
paperwork so I can get out of there and
the dude who recognized me in the lobby
comes up and he stands this far away and
he goes I know who you are mr. comedian
and I go well nice to meet you man he
goes yeah he goes a widow I tell my wife
you were here
what and he goes yeah yeah I go do you
feel like you really need to do that and
he was like yeah she's a big fan man
big fan I just got to tell her and I go
okay that's fine and he was yeah then he
goes can you fill this out for her
I know sure and he was can you sign it
make it funny somewhat about being in
the jerk-off doctors office I'm like
so I'm starting to fill it out and he
looks at me and he goes I saw you walk
out of there all sweaty he what was
happening in there and I said you should
definitely check other and he goes ok
and then he goes mean yous away like I
can't wait to tweet about this I go no
dude you can't tweet about it he goes
one on I go with it because we live in a
country of stories you don't remember
facts you remember stories when you
think of Charlie Sheen you don't think a
platoon Ferris Bueller's Day Off dudes
had a bunch of hits you know you think
of hookers and crack because we remember
stories and I don't want to be sweaty
jerk-off guy for the rest of my [ __ ]
life I mean it's like oh dude don't
tweet he goes I'm gonna have to tweet
man I'm so sorry but I'm gonna get so
many followers when I tell people you
were here and I was like [ __ ] and I'm
about to sign my name and he goes off
wait'll I tell everybody that I'm at
Dane Cook and I was like Dane
[Applause]
walk out of there feeling pretty [ __ ]
good about myself about it so you
watched that video that's a video it's a
man I guess I probably shot that a
couple years ago in Denver at Comedy
Works downtown easily one of the best
three clubs in the country but here we
go
I hate watching old videos of pain
because I think I'm so much better now
than I was then I don't know why it
looks like I got a black guy but I do I
don't like I but it definitely it looks
like so what am I to do now though
because his joke is so Oh
for me and here's another thing you need
to know about the way I tell stories
like I've picked this up this joke and
put it down and picked it up and put it
down and picked it up and put it down a
number of times so I would still
consider this to be new although people
have heard this cuz I haven't taken it
out on the road and done an entire tour
with it every night tinkering with it
[ __ ] with it trying it super high
trying it super not high like trying it
every different way that I tried it
sitting on the stool trying to no stool
everything and then I pick up what works
on the stool what works in front of the
mic what works while I'm moving what
works when I'm animated what works when
I'm still all that stuff I discover when
I take it out for an entire tour right I
haven't gone over this joke yet because
I I don't know I every time I do it I'm
like yeah but not yet and so but I'm
gonna play this for you and kind of I'll
tell you the what I know are bad habits
I guess I saw a bunch of bad habits in
there I tell you there's there are a
couple of tells that I have when I'm not
confident with a joke and I'll point
those out to you too in an area of the
joke if I'm not super confident I have
some of those towels in there too and
how the joke changed and where it is now
and all that stuff so let's give it a
shot you know I think this will be fun
if it's not fun then
what the [ __ ] all right so let's play
here's the joke Josh goes a fertility
clinic here we go
my wife we already have three kids
coming but she was talking about have
another kid and I was like that that
sounds pretty [ __ ] dumb we have all
kids like I'm not realistic you don't go
back in for another 18 that's [ __ ]
dog that's really dumb you know what I
mean like if I wouldn't know what to do
with a [ __ ] baby right now okay right
away I can tell you I'm not sure about
this joke
cuz I've said you know what I mean a
couple times back to back so I'm
thinking I'm not just doing I'm thinking
and you can tell what I'm thinking
because I throw in those phrases that
buy me time and you know what I mean is
one of those raisins so already I know
watching this as so many a couple years
later he's getting it two or three years
later that's somebody two or three years
later I already know I'm not super
confident maybe not in this might not be
the entire joke but this particular part
of a joke I can tell I'm not to copy
what you have babies are like farts
because you love your own but if you had
to sit in a car with somebody else's
with the windows rolled up you'd be like
I'm a [ __ ] kill this [ __ ]
right now excessive swearing excessive
swearing where it's not needed also a
sign for me that I'm not super confident
with the joke I can tell what I'm
confident because I swear a normal life
but to use [ __ ] and [ __ ] and
[ __ ] like God it tells me also
and I'm not too sure about this joke
these are tells for me you know what I
mean these are how I can tell what's
happening with my joke it's crazy to
watch it's okay
so but I told her I was like yeah you
won't have again she was aghast she said
but I need you to go to the fertility
clinic cuz I smoked a lot of weed she
was like you know weed is really bad for
your semen which made me laugh when she
told me cuz I was I was just picturing
my sperm swimming around inside of her
like Gigi ja no no no I'm not gonna hang
down near the walls just so you know I'm
terrible at accents I have since tried
to do either Cheech or Chong accent when
I do this joke and it comes off soon and
super racist so I don't do that anymore
excuse me but yeah I remember the night
I thought about that on stage I was
actually hot and I was picturing and
guys I was picturing my sperm just being
so lazy just hanging out on the wall
watching other sperm or whatever
swimming around like [ __ ] this well I'm
not swimming up there what's up there I
don't know what's up there but I know
it's down here a wall you know so I've
got a bunch of long ribs on at the four
on stage as Cheech or Chong
I don't really know who's accent I was
trying to do but this is the one just
this part is the only part that ever
consistently works so I just think with
what consistently works I don't want
something in there that works 70 percent
of the time and if it works 70 percent
of time by the way I think the reason it
doesn't work another percent of time is
I think it's probably my fault I haven't
cracked the code if it works that much
70 percent of the time I should be able
to figure it out but also sometimes when
I go on these long rents it makes the
joke so so by the way that's where I can
just tell where I put the swears it
tells me I'm not comfortable
I was like yeah has anybody in here been
to her fertility clinic just me and my
old balls are good here we go
well I'll tell you something right now
there are some awkward situations you
find yourself in I've never found myself
in a more awkward situation than being
in the lobby at the jerk-off doctor's
office because by the way jerk-off
doctor's office is one of those things I
stumbled onto on stage also that gets
more laughs than I ever thought of I
don't know why maybe it's the
alliteration
maybe so wait you know I don't maybe
it's the way it just sounds funny but
jerk off doc jerk off doctor always get
it doesn't get like yeah but against
more of a reaction than I ever thought
of never tell that I ever thought it
would look you're sitting in a lobby
with seven dudes all strangers
everybody's just waiting to go jerk off
it's bizarre there's no eye contact some
dude tried to shake my hand then I was
like [ __ ] you we are not shaking any Hey
look there are some times in my life
where it's nice to be recognized and
there's some places where I don't want
to be recognized like the jerk-off
doctor's office and let me tell you why
the jerk-off doctors you know the one
thing I added to that and I don't know
why I added it cuz it doesn't help it
doesn't make it funny it doesn't look it
it doesn't make it funny I don't know
why but I just I I add it in Hey look
anybody in my I've worked hard in my
career and sometimes it's really nice to
be recognized this is what I've added it
sometimes it's really nice to be
recognized and anybody in my position
who tells you that it's not nice to be
recognized or not nice to have somebody
come up and say hello every now in that
or tell you how much they love you
anyone who tells you that is terrible
all the time is lying he's lying come on
man to have people like you is a [ __ ]
crazy amazing have strangers be like a
man you really helped me through some
[ __ ] oh my god it's amazing and I have
people recognize to say they like you
but but you don't call your shot you
don't announce it to other people do you
know what I mean it's not like the game
Clue where you're like it's Josh in the
living room with a sock do you know
today like I said do you know what I
mean a couple times there but here's one
punch line by the way
as I watch this in the first two minutes
there are no more different punch lines
however I'm a better comic so I'm
watching this and for whatever reason
the first two minutes gets more laughs
now maybe it's the way I deliver it I
honestly can't tell you what it is I'm
gonna have to record it and take a look
but the one thing I added to this was
it's Josh and delivering with a sock and
the candlestick
you know candlestick good visual
candlestick is a funny word candlestick
nice extra little pop in there I don't
know if these jokes sounds funny me
saying I'm like this but trust me when I
say it works on stage but the
candlestick was one of the ones that was
just a little one again that I just
found somewhere because I happened to be
making a joke in the green room that
night about the pudding not me about it
hospitals found a candlestick in
somebody's ass dude stare
I turn to him in he goes I know you and
I said no you know by the way I'm gonna
kill you something remember this moment
at 2 minutes and 54 seconds in everybody
there was something right here a few
like maybe a minute not a minute maybe
10 seconds or 15 seconds after this that
isn't there because Bert Kreischer gave
me a great tip when he watched this one
night and I'll tell you what it is at
the end because you need to watch the
whole thing too but it's it's crazy how
it changed the entire story what's your
name again and just send from encounter
the woman she said mr. Kameda you want
to come on up here and fill your
paperwork and I was like okay so I walk
up there now I know none of you have
ever been to a fertility clinic but let
me tell you there are two questions on
the paperwork that I would that stumped
me question number one how do you plan
on making your deposit today
masturbation or other and I was like
well I got a [ __ ] question right now
here's crazy to that other I would wait
1/2 beat more before I said a happy
masturbation other that might even be a
little long I would have jumped a little
soon but that was a little quick just a
little quick it's funny how you feel
timing a little off and that was a
little off I said what's other and she
goes do you play no masturbating I go
well it kind of depends on what other is
doesn't it because if you're sending in
nurse other I'll check that box right
now I struggled with that joke for a
long time I tried so many so many jokes
that didn't work so many about what
other is so many and I was at the doctor
once and I asked what I was still trying
to figure this joke out and there was a
nurse and her last name was o h ER i was
like well that's pretty [ __ ] close to
other laughs so I started to go to nurse
other and always gets a good job she was
like I can't tell you what it is like
are you telling me there's there's an
alternative to masturbation that's so
good you have any [ __ ] named it yet
you're not gonna tell us what it is she
goes I really can't okay she goes maybe
I can tell you later okay the next
question that stumped me stumped me
how much do you plan on depositing today
yeah I don't know jerk-off in a
measuring cup of my house oh all of it
I'm not gonna be in the other room like
this all of it I don't need a doggie bag
all of it you know so that is what just
watching that for me is painful so okay
so okay again I don't know how funny
it's gonna be telling you about it here
but the order and the pace and sometimes
you just get people in a rhythm and they
laugh and so it was supposed to go how
much do you plan on deposit by the way
that snoring is my daughter be hearing
this how much do you plan on deposit day
I don't know all of it I'm not gonna be
in the back room then you go all over
the place right little for you I don't
take off in a measuring cup in my house
today [ __ ] all of it I don't need a
doggie bag so for whatever reason that
role really works this who just watching
it makes me angry yeah uh-huh
watch if you can't tell I chipped his
tooth recently this one's fake I didn't
[ __ ] I ran into a door when I was a kid
see how that's short huh I wish I gave
up fun I get it sick
all right she was like go sit down I'm
like walk into the lobby and the dude
was like hey man I don't know a couple
minutes later she goes okay so I also
messed that up when I say the dude the
reason that didn't get a laugh in this
particular joke
the dude who recognized me right I'm
supposed to say goes hey man this
particular joke depending on how I say
no it depends on if I gotta live that
way when I said no I didn't get I got a
chuckle but sometimes I just go nope and
for whatever reason guys sometimes you
can't explain the joke or the last or
the reason there's a lot like you wrote
it down on paper nope that's not getting
the chuckle but for whatever reason at
the end there when I do it and I say
nope it gets a laugh I tried a lot of
things I tried to [ __ ] you I tried a lot
of different I tried to beat it out a
little more it just for whatever reason
nope and I think it's a lot as I do it
the harp sound but that works better
than anything in sometimes different
combinations work better like maybe not
in this particular joke but the note
works just because of what you led up
with and if you let up with something
else to note wouldn't work it's so
[ __ ] maddening hazard omission goes
it's your turn okay I go into the room
and I walk into this room and right away
guys I know there's no way I can
masturbate there
it was a testament that room was a
testament to how gross
dudes oh yeah let me tell you how gross
dudes are the couch that I was supposed
to sit on covered in plastic which means
they had washed it so many times that
the dude was like Nietzsche's gonna
[ __ ] wrap that up you know what's
funny is that like some jokes you keep
for a while because you hope they're
gonna get a lot man I love that wrapped
in plastic he's gonna wrap that up for
whatever reason when I was writing that
out man I was like this is gonna make me
laugh and it doesn't but I keep it in
because it makes me laugh I actually
have recently taken it out of this joke
in particular because I found it was
gross some people I'll tell you kind of
where the RAM I'm in now after we get
through this part their remote control
that I was supposed to hold covered in
plastic I'm gonna go one step further
and how gross dudes are the front of the
television was covered in plastic that
means something jerked off on the TV it
was like
[Music]
this is one of those happy accidents man
I remember this is the first show that
this happened because now I do it every
show this is one of those things that
happy accidents at 5:00 you find on
stage and you're like some of them never
work again sometimes it works that first
night and it's in the moment it's magic
and it happens you try to repeat it the
next night be like that eats dead so
I'll try it again each six again this
particular one happens to work every
time and I added a little bit in it I do
that and then I say man I didn't mean to
fake jerk off on it always gets a laugh
but it's one of those things where
you're like man it's why you have to be
free to play and on stage you have to
have your framework right but you have
to give yourself license to work outside
of it every night because if not I would
have never found that I would have never
found that so I didn't mean to fake your
jerk off on you always makes me laugh
and always gets a good chuckle in the
crowd
I was aiming at you though so I was like
me I don't want to touch anything at all
but I know so what I basically done I've
taken out the couch and I've taken out
the light switch and I've just started
talking about the TV because the TV is
the only thing they got the laughs the
couch and the lights which helped paint
the room so I do I do give a better
visual of what the room looks like you
know when you when I tell stories I want
you to feel like you're there you know
so I can't explain the room who walk
into a room and if I'm gonna be in that
room and what the room looks like is
important I can't move forward without
explaining it to you so in your head
you're picturing what I you don't have
sad important ones to my wife so I was
like okay and then I remember her
telling me that when she's in a place in
a bathroom that's dirty that she doesn't
want to sit on the toilet she hovers
right you all hover over the seat so I
was like oh I'll just I'll hover jerk so
I get to right here and I'm I'm
masturbating and I'm about 20 seconds in
and I was like my [ __ ] quads are
burning right I was sweating profusely
I'm like [ __ ] CrossFit this is the best
workout I've ever had in my entire life
I'm gonna come in a [ __ ] it open up
a:hover jerks to do and close down
CrossFit like right now I'm sweating you
know it's funny one word changes the
laughs at the end of that so and this I
said I put cross without a bit right now
right and I changed it to I'm gonna open
a Harvard jerk studio and put CrossFit
out of business always gets a lot for
whatever reason put crossed without a
business again no rhyme or reason but
these little things when you go back and
you nitpick your jokes sometimes you can
trim 1015 seconds and just taking the
air out of it
increases the laugh so much but that one
one word and getting rid of right now
work so much I'm cramping cramping and
I'm like I need some water right so I
start to walk out to the front and I'm
sweating guys I'm breathing heavy I'm
cramping so I'm limping sweat dripping
off my face and I'm walking out to the
front like some weird survivor I'm like
so people always like the laughs but
I've set it up differently so now it
gets a big bigger laugh I say all that
stuff cramping sweating I say so I went
out I needed a new I needed water so I
went to the front debt front desk to get
some water but I didn't realize that I
walked out of the jerk-off room like
this and then I do that walk and it
always four-way again I'm trying to put
you in the lobby
watching me limp and breathe heavily
walking out of jerk offer and the woman
was like
are you okay and I said I think I'm
gonna need to know what other is so I
love that line but I probably rubbed my
leg for like three or four more seconds
just to make the people in the audience
think what is he gonna say in in the
longer I get away from the question the
last people expect me to say I'm gonna
no need to know what hello no no just
comedy nerd [ __ ] guys she said I can't
tell you that but I get your water I go
okay I drink the water I go back in the
room I finish up and he goes I know who
you are mr. comedian I know
nice to meet you man he was yeah he goes
over here but and he goes yeah yeah I go
do you feel like you really need to do
that and he was like yeah she's a big
fan man
big fan I just gotta tell her I go okay
that's fine he was yeah so again I think
it's because I'm can you hear him
snoring I think it's because I'm a
better comedian than I was but when I
described him and his wife his wife
right when I described him and his wife
I say well I was a big fan right and
wait til I tell her you were here and I
think it's the length that I pause and I
say really did what every not guys when
I say laughs I'm not talking about
and I'm saying just little chuckles
throughout your joke that take away long
chunks of just being in the store right
you still want the highs and P DS and
all that [ __ ] you know and some of my
most popular jokes they're they're
minutes where there aren't heavy laughs
but I'm taking you through the story you
know
can you fill this out I know sure news
can you sign it make it funny someone
about being the jerk-off doctor's office
okay one of the things and again I don't
know why this gets a lot but making it a
jerk-off doctor's office right in this I
go okay it now I go no oh
again not sure why always get to left
these little things really these so I'm
talking about like four or five little
laughs that I've added in it boosts the
entire experience of the joke in the
timing and taking away some of those
extra words so I'm taking away words and
I'm adding into the laughs which make
the laughs when I'm taking out things
and adding laughter it makes the laughs
come more often now too right
this [ __ ] snore now I do say some
other way you see me laughing
I don't know something really do dude
labs of this joke laugh yeah and laugh
at the jokes for a couple reasons one
guys I'm having a [ __ ] good time I
love I love it and so but most
importantly I'm reliving the store I
really try to make it seem like I'm
telling you the story for the first time
so in order to do that I have to relive
the story so I put myself in there so
when I picture this guy every time I
picture him say this stupid [ __ ] it
makes me laugh because I know how it
went
right so it always makes me giggle
because I'm trying to put myself in that
spot again next to this dumb
[ __ ] I said [ __ ] not
because I'm uncomfortable but because
that's wait so you walk out of there all
sweaty and then he goes away like I
can't wait to tweet about this I go no
dude you can't tweet about it he goes
one on I go with the because we live in
a country of stories you don't remember
facts you remember stories when you
think of Charlie Sheen you don't think a
platoon Ferris Bueller's Day Off dudes
had a bunch of hits you know you think
of hookers and crack because we remember
stories and I don't want to be sweaty
jerk oh yeah I've taken that whole
Charlie Sheen thing out of there
if we don't need it if people understand
what I'm saying
I'm never gonna need jokes out of it
never know laughs and so I just could I
just go straight to the we live in a
country they don't care about we like
stories we remember stories and I don't
want to be sweaty jerk-off
Birkhoff guy for the rest of my [ __ ]
life so I go dude don't tweet he goes
I'm gonna have to tweet man I'm so sorry
but I'm gonna get so many followers when
I tell people you were here and I was
like [ __ ] I'm about to sign my name and
he goes oh wait till I tell everybody
that I'm a Dane Cook and I was like dang
walk out of there feeling pretty [ __ ]
good about myself okay so listen so the
end of that here's the truth the end of
that happened in the middle when I was
in the lobby with the guy for the first
time and I was struggling with an ending
for the joke struggling struggling
struggling struggling for an ending with
the joke and Bert Kreischer saw it one
night a little place called the haha
cafe in North Hollywood out here and I
was like I'm struggling man I'm
struggling will you watch this
to help me account it with the ending
and he said man put that danger yeah I
said what he goes it's such a funny
reveal that the guy thought you were
Dane Cook that it should be the end that
that's right at the end there when
you're signing you should be signing
Dane Cook and I was like [ __ ] you're
right you're right it does because your
deal my deal with stories is I try to
stick to as much of the truth as I can I
think the truth is always funnier and
the truth allows me to be more natural
and all that [ __ ] you know but it's also
like really important to you know it's
really important to you know make it
funny so I am trying here to not hurt
the integrity of the joke because it is
kind of not kind of it is who he thought
I was I just put it at the end because
the impact is so much bigger and I know
people have said to me didn't do your
[ __ ] slam and dang no I'm actually
not about it it's actually like honestly
if I was making things up I would have
said the guy thought I looked like
Daniel Tosh because ray borrowed Iowa I
love
Daniel Tosh I get it I get it
white trash talk trailer trash talk or
talks
oh I get it [ __ ] get it the truth matter
is dude said Dan cook and to me it was
funnier because I don't look anything
like that cook so it's not a slam on day
yeah but I did feel pretty good about
myself because I loved practical jokes
and I wasn't gonna correct that dude I
wanted him to go home but then cook
wasn't the jerk off doctors offals yeah
but that's it man I like doing this
maybe we'll do a few more of them let me
know what you think I hope you can see
the final you know I'm gonna do I'm
gonna post the final version of this
joke
stay safe everybody love you make sure
you hit that [ __ ] notification button
see you next time
[Music]
you